as much as we joke about whiteness on
this show
i do have some sympathy for white people
there's a lot of pressure on you all to
be constant perfect allies right now and
that's such a hard energy to keep up
forever
when will you finally be able to stop
talking about race
when can you all stop making calls to
your congress people
when can the nba appeal their black
lives matter vinyl off the floor to make
space for a citibank ad
i know how you all love citibank ads
well don't you worry because
i've got an idea to solve it introducing
the white forgiveness clock okay
okay so here's the deal this clock is
gonna run for a whole 48 hours and
all we have to do as a nation is get
through two whole days without a big
transgression against black people
and then you're free you can all stop
retweeting black activists and reading
books and go back to using twitter to
argue about whether
certain tall white celebrities are hot
or not it's easy
anyway i'm just gonna let that run while
we go on with the show because i have
something very exciting
because it's time for a new segment of
the show called
who's that little cutie
[Music]
this is the part of the show where i
show you guys some of my favorite little
cuties that i've seen on the internet
this week
and boy have i got a doozy for you all
the first little cutie is a sneezing
baby snake
and he oh hey amber sorry to uh
interrupt but i just got a news alert
what's up
um a black child in colorado just got
arrested by seven cops
because his white neighbors thought he
was breaking into his own house
what good lord that's awful yeah
and that means we got to reset the clock
ugh okay
all right everybody that was a bad start
i thought for sure we'd get further than
that
but uh you know what america we gotta do
better
as a nation okay back to the little
cuties because you guys are just gonna
flip
okay so i was telling you about this
little snake he's sneezing because
he's allergic to his tiny little teddy
bear
amber i just got another alert come on
are ready
yeah middle school in missouri is taking
down a confederate statue
well that's good and replacing it with a
bigger one what why would they do that
i didn't even think missouri was part of
the confederacy they weren't
okay all right maybe 48 hours was too
long let's try
24 hours okay so uh oh
uh trump is on twitter calling kamala
harris
loud and uppity oh let's try one hour
oh god another one yeah they just
announced green book two
[Music]
okay this is insane but uh
it shouldn't be some big ordeal not to
do racist things
i thought this year was going to be a
time where people look inward at their
own actions and
do their best to change i don't want to
believe that america is an unfixable
country or that black people are just
meant to be burdened forever
i want to believe in your goodness
because i love this country
and i won't stop believing in its
goodness even when it can't seem to
believe in mine
oh no taylor swift just released
a cover of electric boogie unplug the
clock
just unplug it
[Music]
you